are you a developer who runs workloads
on kubernetes or gke
well if you are then you're probably
familiar with prometheus the de facto
standard for open source monitoring on
kubernetes and you probably know that
managing prometheus at scale can be a
real big challenge sometimes my name is
yuri i'm an sre at google cloud and
today i'm going to show you how to use
google's managed service for prometheus
to monitor your gk workloads without
having to manually manage prometheus at
scale this is engineering for
reliability
the first thing to understand is the
nature of the service itself
this is google cloud's fully managed
service for prometheus metrics it's
built on top of monarch the same
globally scalable data store as cloud
monitoring you can replace your existing
prometheus deployment to collect cluster
and workload metrics and then query the
data across multiple clusters using prom
qr sounds intriguing i'm so glad let's
have a look at how you can get started
let's start by validating our existing
prometheus deployment
here we can see that we have all of the
necessary components running this
includes the prometheus server itself
the node exporter which collects
infrastructure metrics from our cluster
nodes and the grafana ui
next let's make sure that metric
collection is working
we can connect to the prometheus server
ui using portfolio
run a query to confirm that metrics are
being collected and then we're able to
query them
at this point we're ready to migrate
this installation to send metrics to the
managed prometheus service
[Music]
the prometheus operator is using a
prometheus custom resource to manage
these components
we can edit it
and simply replace the image it's using
with google's forked version of the
prometheus server
[Music]
this binary is configured to scrape both
workload metrics and its own metrics
endpoint and send the collected data to
the managed service backend
once we confirm that the server has
restarted let's again validate local
metric collection and querying using
port forwarding
[Music]
everything still works as expected
but now we can go to the cloud console
and run our query there
this confirms that these metrics are
being ingested properly
we can also query the same metrics using
metrics explorer for example and use it
to create charts or alerts
[Music]
[Music]
so if you're already running prometheus
in your gk cluster you can easily
migrate to the google cloud manage your
service for prometheus and ingest your
metrics into cloud monitoring just by
replacing the prometheus binary it's
just that easy
thanks so much for watching today we
learned how google's managed service for
prometheus allows you to monitor your
clusters without having to manage
prometheus manually how to migrate your
existing prometheus setup and how to use
promptql to query the data next time
we'll instrument our own application and
configure prometheus monitoring for it
don't forget to like and subscribe to
never miss out on more engineering for
reliability with google cloud see you
soon
[Music]